good evening we start the news hour with
some breaking news and president Trump
has imposed tough new sanctions on Iran
specifically targeted at the country's
supreme leader in response to the
shooting down of an American drone mr.
Trump says the United States does not
want conflict but Iran will not be
allowed to get nuclear weapons
our correspondent Amanda Walker joins me
from Washington so Amanda he pulled back
at the last moment from military action
but new sanctions announced now new
sanctions they flirted with military
action didn't they and they seem now
confident that economic punishment is
the way forward with Iran so this is
just coming in to us mark as we speak he
has confirmed that he's signing an
executive order imposing hard-hitting
sanctions on Iran going straight to the
top saying that the order will deny the
supreme leader and others access to
financial instruments Donald Trump says
we will continue to increase pressure on
Tehran never can Iran have a nuclear
weapon which ultimately is what these
sanctions are all about now in the
run-up to getting ready for that
military strike apparently Donald Trump
was told by his Secretary of State that
the maximum pressure campaign which is
really these sanctions is having the
desired effect some analysts say that
Iran's oil revenue is down 2/3 so I
think he certainly feels bolstered by
that and that's why they're continuing
with this he says that the new executive
order on sanctions was going to happen
regardless of the drones shoot down and
of course the deal maker in chief also
adding that he would love to get a deal
with Iran he says I think a lot of
restraint has been shown by us but that
doesn't mean we're going to show it in
the future and that echoes what he said
in an interview over the weekend he said
we don't want to go to war but if we did
it would be obliteration it's a
possibility he likes to use that as a
threat really while saying economic
sanctions are the way we
is basically the best way to get around
to start complying to start showing that
it's going to back down that so far
maximum pressure is only being met with
maximum defiance and resistance as we
can see those continued acts that the
Trump administration say is pure
provocation whether it's the oil tankers
the shooting down of the drone so far
it's hard to see how this campaign is
working other than the fact that the
economy in Iran is really struggling
yeah okay a man who just stay there a
second I think we can hear now from
President Trump about these sanctions
signing an executive order imposing
hard-hitting sanctions on the supreme
leader of Iran and the office of the
Supreme Leader of Iran and many others
today's action follows a series of
aggressive behaviors by the Iranian
regime in recent weeks including
shooting down of US drones and you shut
down the drone that's I guess everyone
saw that one and many other things
they've done many other things aside
from the individual drone you saw the
tankers and we know of other things that
were done also which were not good and
not appropriate the Supreme Leader of
Iran is one who ultimately is
responsible for the hostile conduct of
the regime he's respected within his
country his office oversees the regime's
most brutal instruments and clearly the
Islamic Revolutionary Guard for
sanctions imposed through the executive
order that I'm about to sign will deny
the Supreme Leader and the Supreme
Leader's office and those closely
affiliated with him and the office
access to key financial resources and
support the assets of Ayatollah Khomeini
and his office will not be spared from
the sanctions these measures represent a
strong and proportionate response to
Iran's increasingly provocative actions
we will continue to increase pressure on
terrorists until the regime abandons its
dangerous activities and its aspirations
including the pursuit of nuclear weapons
increased enrichment of uranium
development of ballistic missiles and
changement and support for terrorism
fuelling of foreign conflicts and
belligerent acts directed against the
United States and its allies the
agreement that was signed was a disaster
it was not doing what it was supposed to
do many bad things were taking place and
most importantly it was so short-term
that within a very short number of years
they would be able to make nuclear
weapons and that's unacceptable
never can Iran have a nuclear weapon
also included in this is we want the
stoppage immediately of their sponsoring
of terrorism they sponsor terrorism of
the level that nobody's ever seen before
and that's been over the last number of
years and they've taken all of that
money that was given to them by the past
administration and much of it was given
out to terrorist organizations in fact I
remember when John Kerry was asked a
question about whether or not this money
will be spent for terror he actually
said yes or at least he was referring to
some of it but he said yes it will be it
will be used for terror with if you can
believe that we give it a money we're
saying yes he can be used to terror that
was not a good answer
but that was the least of it frankly so
America is a peace-loving nation we do
not seek conflict with Iran or any other
country I look forward to the day when
sanctions can be finally lifted and Iran
can become a peaceful prosperous and
productive nation that can go very
quickly it can be tomorrow it could also
be in years from now so I look forward
to discussing whatever I have to discuss
with anybody that wants to speak in the
meantime who knows what's going to
happen I can only tell you we cannot
ever let Iran have a nuclear weapon and
it won't happen and secondly and very
importantly we don't want money going
out to sponsor terror
so you're the number one sponsor of
Terror anywhere in the world so I'll
sign this order right now
and I want to thank our military I want
to thank all of the people that have
been working with me over the last
number of months on this I think a lot
of restraint has been shown by us a lot
of restraint and that doesn't mean we're
going to show it in the future but I
felt that we want to give give this a
chance give it a good chance because I
think Iran potentially has a phenomenal
future just and I say that about North
Korea too I've said it about North Korea
I think North Korea has a phenomenal
future and I think Iran also has a
phenomenal future and it would like to I
think a lot of people would like to see
them get to work on that great future so
I'll sign this now and I appreciate you
all being here thank you from signing
that order for tough new sanctions on
Iran Amanda Walker is still with us in
Washington Amanda interesting to see how
Europe reacts to this and also
interesting that he says there he still
wants talks and he he doesn't want
conflict is it significant that he's
targeting personally the supreme leader
Ayatollah how many has had his calls for
talks rejected by the leader so is this
a response to that but it's interesting
the sort of language that Trump is using
they're suggesting that Iran could have
a great future he's trying a bit of his
flattery that he has done with North
Korea suggesting that he could be the
person to take things into a completely
new era when it comes to US relations
and that really appeals to Donald Trump
the idea that he could have a
breakthrough on these issues that have
plagued the US for decades whether it's
North Korea Iran that he could be the
one to see a new dawn in those relations
he talked about showing restraint which
certainly some people here analysts have
been saying you know we criticize Donald
Trump a lot but in pulling back at the
11th hour he did show restraint
the next day the US and the world was in
a much better position than it would
have been if he had pressed go and
that's also adding that they may not
show that restraint in the future so
he's trying to keep his powder dry they
are confident that Iran is being
punished by these sanctions that that is
the way to continue if they want Iran to
eventually sort of go the way and comply
and keep going on that path which is all
about they saying they're not having a
nuclear weapon which is of course what
that Obama Iran deal was all about but
it was one of the first things when he
came into office that Donald Trump
wanted to dismantle he says it was a
terrible deal and he wants to get his
own deal hey Amanda thank you very much